guys how are you are they better than we
deserve Dave welcome where you guys live
Indianapolis oh cool well welcome to
Nashville and here to do a debt-free
scream yes we are very good very cool
and how much debt have you paid off
we've paid off one hundred and
twenty-five thousand dollars very good
and how long did that take well it took
me about twenty seven months and then
Brian joined the join the March about
fifteen months ago so all very cool so
tois it took 27 months for me we we were
we just got married about a year ago
this is our one-year anniversary present
to ourselves
very cool good and your range of income
during this time but if you combine both
175 to 200 oh my goodness what do you
guys do for a living I'm a physician
assistant and I work full-time Family
Practice but I also have the opportunity
to pick up some nights and weekends in
an urgent care clinic Oh two jobs cool
so what kind of debt was the 125,000 it
was retail both of our cars and a lot of
student loans a lot of okay for those of
you looking into your radio he just
threw her under the bus see the tire
tracks right now so how many so much in
student loan debt did you have Katie um
well I started nine years ago with 120
but by the time I got your program it
was about you know sixty okay so half of
this was student loan debt for Katie yes
okay and how much was your truck right I
don't have a truck I'm trying to help
you Katie I I had a significant amount
of student loans but not not near hers I
got you okay cool so what started you on
this journey Katie and then how did you
get Brian to join you on the journey
well I got your Total Money Makeover
workbook and I started working the
program I just didn't want to be paying
those loans off forever
yeah and then when we got engaged about
a year and a half ago I said I'd love to
marry you but you have to take financial
feast so he kind of came kicking and
screaming and then correct so at at that
point I went to Fe
and then we got to the dumping debt
lesson and I really kind of saw the the
wheels turn in and and we really started
making some significant process probably
gonna cool very cool I mean you love her
a lot if you go to a dead young
financial class so this girl's worth it
like you went to a financial class to
get this all right oh my god oh that's
fun very cool so now that you guys have
done this and Katie you you know
struggle through part of it together and
part of it you guys I mean part of it on
your own then part of it you've done
together what is your advice to dating
engaged couples out there that are
facing the same kind of thing what is
the the key secrets to getting out of
debt that you used I think for us we
kind of just sat down and figured out
what our life goals were going to be and
we wanted to be debt-free by our
one-year anniversary and before we had
children and so now we can kind of you
know do what we want have that freedom
it feels really good yeah and definitely
to treat them as two independent
snowballs really worked for us as well
and then to see once it once we got
married to see those come together and
after joining the finances after the
wedding then to see how that picks up
and takes off yeah quicker cause your
income goes through the roof oh yeah
very cool very cool well guys that's
obviously very incredible what you've
done
Wall Street Journal came out with a
study a while back that said that the
average person in America is like 16
years worth of debt you guys just paid
it off in one year really cool stuff
those of you listening and you're
thinking man if I had that kind of
income well they have a lot of debt to
that's a big number
now we teach 168 hours in the week for
you to be able to work or sleep and be
able to recreation you did two jobs you
didn't work 40 hours you didn't work 50
probably didn't work 60 you worked more
than that and you lived oh my goodness
what would be your advice will be your
encouragement to those that are kind of
reluctant to take that second job you
just got a it's good you just got to
know that it's temporary one of the
things I don't think that we mentioned
is we also cashflow $22,000 for our
wedding Wow so the it would be on top of
that so
just working through Katie did a lot of
the lion's share of the work because she
she had the available for the second job
so I learned how to cook and do dishes
and and that type of thing I want to say
Bryan does work full-time reason he
works - yeah but yet for me it was
really hard being patient I think cause
it's kind of like alright alright
by the time I got to that last monster
alone yeah it slows down this debt
snowball feels like it slows down when
you get to that one you don't have those
milestones yeah I got it yeah I got yeah
it's not I'm not there to help you well
congratulations you two very very proud
of ya thank you if you were to go did
you have some people cheering you on in
the background some friends and family
helping we sure did people watching at
home family and friends very cool very
good good well I'm glad that's awesome
we're gonna give you a signed copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book
number one bestseller that's the next
chapter in your story now become wealthy
and outrageously generous and have an
absolutely awesome future now that
you've set yourself up to do that Brian
and Katie Indianapolis $125,000 paid off
in twenty seven and twelve months and
making one hundred seventy five a year
total combined count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream three two one
that's how it's done you guys very very
very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common